what do you think about gray man having
a limited one-week theatrical run no i
don't like it i mean i think netflix's
theatrical
uh plans are just in disarray they don't
have a theatrical component to their
films netflix needs a theatrical
component because
at the end of the day we all know this
it's just it's a fact
when a film is in theaters
you its visibility is higher it's got
more cachet
it just that's how because that's that's
how i was as a kid i mean we all went to
movies there was no such thing as day
and date at home right like netflix or
disney plus or any of these things that
the hulu any name of name the streaming
service
it was all about theatrical and anything
that wasn't theatrical was a tv movie so
it wasn't viewed with the same lens it
was like this is a lesser film because
it's not on the big screen and that's
netflix's challenge is
getting people to accept them as a
studio
such as warner brothers disney 20th
century obviously part of disney sony
universal these studios paramount that
have the legacy
that netflix does not have but the way
you build legacy is you have to have a
theatrical component so when i look at
the gray man a film that's i believe a
200 million dollar budget with the russo
brothers 200 million dollar film and you
don't have it in theaters beyond one
week and by the way not even the major
change not amc not regal it is you know
cinemark or even smaller and and you
have this 200 million film you have to
have at least a 30 to 45 day window
theatrical window right these be 90. so
let's give it 30 that's a month a month
before it's on netflix it's at amc regal
the major chains figure out some kind of
sharing i don't know how the profits
work with with all that stuff the ins
and outs the numbers but i know this
they need to get that because it will
add cache to their film so instantly
when you ask them about the gray man i
say ah it's lesser because it's not a
theatrical film it's not um you know a
universal release or a warner brothers
release it is it is going to be on
netflix a week after and again we can't
even in l.a it's gonna be very hard to
find theatrically so netflix has to
figure out how to get their theatrical
game going i can't believe they don't
have it done by now i mean it is i'm
hearing finally you're hearing these
stories and the trades that they're
thinking about i'm like thinking about
it how did you not do this like a year
or two ago i've been saying this for
forever it's such a vital part of the
visibility of a film is the theatrical
component
okay do you think some of their
reasoning behind this is like pressure
buy
like hey this sort of like this is only
on sale for this weekend folks so
because of rising costs and things like
that
give people one week now there's
pressure we want to see this on the big
screen no i think i think that's that's
the op the flip of that so because it's
only one week now you're telling
audiences you only have to wait a week
to see it
look at paramount and what they just did
with top gun maverick they gave it a 120
day theatrical window that is four
months that's longer than the the old
90.
so
what you do when you announce that it's
a four-month theatrical exclusive you
are forcing people to go to the movie
theater to see your film
and um and i think the
listen i think we're in a different
place now than we were in 2020 certainly
when co would first hit i think if you
look around look at the audiences i'm
seeing it films now it's back to the
2019 pre-print pre-pandemic levels
so
why not
give audiences the opportunity to go see
it at a theater where it's going to be
that communal experience where it's
going to be something that they're going
to remember far more than watching it at
home i mean every single time theatrical
beats home viewing
99.99
of the time so unless someone's on their
cell phone okay or talking or kicking
your chair those are those are separate
issues but the actual experience of
watching on a big screen with a crowd in
your recliner if you paid the up charge
these are all better and i think that
another thing that's that's really great
about films and i think about going back
to watching top gun maverick uh just you
know last week seeing
young kids and older folk right next to
me this wide swath of all ages going to
this film this might have been their
first film back into a theater right
because they've been you know had
coveted they've done the whole thing and
maybe they were a little leery about
going back then they go to see topka
maverick
and they take the precautions they need
to take but they say to themselves hey
you know that wasn't so bad
and now i think i'm over my fear and now
i'm gonna get out and not just go see
movies i'm gonna go live life more than
i have in the past two years so movies
are the vehicle for so many other things
i mean just think about that breaking
that plane of being frightened of going
outside your house and all of a sudden
you go to see top gun maverick and you
come out first of all i love the movie
second of all
i'm alive a few days later
hey
let's go try this and this and this and
then you regain where we were before
which is so important right living life
fearlessly because if you if you're
living a life of fear um obviously
you're not living so i think again uh
just think about taking something small
like that and then extrapolating it out
and saying wow look at what it just did
for for somebody i think about that too
so shortening the window of opportunity
for theatrical actually has the opposite
effect 100 yeah yeah shortening the
theatrical window absolutely
makes your film it puts it in peril uh
box office wise because people are now
going to say i can wait 17 days
certainly i can wait a week but even you
know look at hbo max was doing that all
throughout the pandemic pandemic day and
date right it was on hbo max and it was
in theaters and look what happened every
one of them suffered because if you give
people the opportunity to watch a movie
at home they're going to take it nine
times out of ten right eight times down
to seven most people are gonna go i'm
gonna stay home um i'll say it's cheaper
uh i don't have to drive to the theater
whatever it is so i think if you give
them the opportunity to watch at home
you're gonna lose a huge
segment of your movie going public right
right there and then also
people will just say i'll just wait it
out if you tell them it's going to be on
in 17 days if i was running the studio i
don't think i'd even announce
i would just say hey it's in theaters
we'll let you know when it's going to be
on our streaming service because once
you announce it you instantly give
someone a deadline that they know i can
only i only have to wait you know five
weeks i can do that but if you make it
just tba then then they will go i want
to see this movie because right now the
world works certainly on twitter film
twitter and social media is people want
to talk about movies now what are people
talking about now you don't want to be
talking about a film you know three
weeks from now it was like oh my god
that's old we already did that we
already did that discussion i mean
people go to see movies like two days
after the open house so sorry i'm late
to have seen this film it opened two
days ago but that's the world we live in
now it's white hot at the moment so i
think that's what theatrical that's how
it thrives is by
making people go see the movie at the
theater if they want to discuss it and
people want to discuss it so they're
going to go to the theater
how much money do you think the gray man
will make in theaters for this one week
theatrical not much in fact remember
this netflix does not report its box
office we'll never know so they didn't
you know roma had a small theatrical uh
power the dog had it i mean a number of
their films had that one week window
like especially the warts films they
never announced the box office they keep
that down uh army of the dead i believe
had that for a week i think the reports
got out didn't do that well but again
it's not going to do well because
a week is nothing for people to wait
they'll be like whatever and plus
remember it's not at every theater like
if i want to see the gray man i have to
probably go find it at a smaller theater
here in la i can't just go down to amc
because they don't have a deal with amc
so it we'll never know
but i'll bet you it's not very big
because it's not going to be available
everywhere now if it was one week at amc
regal with the larger chains i would say
better
but again the week is not good you
really want to make it a month minimum
because otherwise your fortitude just
wait i'll wait
let's talk about red notice
how much money
would that have made
apparently it was one of netflix's most
popular films streaming all time i mean
you have three major stars in that the
rock gal ryan reynolds you got these
three major stars um i mean if that's a
universal film
um i can remember when that came out it
was like it was still during the
pandemic so we had that would have been
shifted but let's just say red notice
comes out today and it's a universal
film okay that opens with at least 40
plus million
maybe higher even though it's not a
great film
but again average person seems to enjoy
it enough look at the lost city lost
city is a paramount movie obviously with
sandra bullock and
brad and channing and it did very well
for them i think red notices very much
of that and i think it made over 100
million lost cities so i think red
notices easy over a hundred uh domestic
alone probably throughout the world
certainly more because it is uh the rock
will travel ryan reynolds travels gal
would travel all those would go do well
overseas
but it's hard to know because because
it's netflix if it was universal uh i
still think it would probably be about a
45 50 50 million dollar opening and then
at least 100 million box office so
netflix leaves that out right so netflix
doesn't have that all of a sudden um
do they gain more subscribers i'm not
privy to that information
but i just don't understand how you
don't
make money while you can in theaters
for at least a month or two and pocket
that 100 million or so or more
and
and now you don't have that it's just
it's just like leaving money on the
table i don't understand the philosophy
other than to drive people to subscribe
to netflix but i still feel like they're
going to subscribe anyhow they might
want to watch it for a second time at
home so i just think that who
netflix needs to absolutely revamp their
model
certainly for their big films not for
every film but for their big films
you're spending all this money on your
budget 200 million for the grey man and
you're not going to put it in theaters
why it doesn't it just doesn't compute
with me
the business doesn't make sense to me
and again it cheapens your film because
it's not theatrical
what if netflix puts the gray man
exclusively in theaters for one month
and it fails at the box office how much
would a massive failure cost netflix i
know we don't know too much about their
box office numbers right
well first we'd have to know what the
numbers are right so we'd have to know
they'd have to report the actual number
we'd know um but i don't think given its
july
it's a four quad film right largely it's
probably three and a half i mean young
kids are probably not going to see the
great man but let's call it pretty wide
you've got major stars in that film
obviously so you're looking at a very
large chunk of the movie going pie
it does it damage the film if it bombs
um i mean are people going to
unsubscribe from netflix no
so i don't think it does anything
i don't think it affects
netflix as long people aren't going to
unsubscribe and you made at least
something from the film so i'm trying to
ascertain what is the downside of of
putting a film theatrically it doesn't
other than
the sharing the revenue right because
the feeder the chains get their money in
and the studio gets money but still
isn't any money better than no money
plus the subscribers again it just
doesn't work
i can't get my wrap my mind around it
are movie theaters upset that netflix
has hurt their business
they probably they definitely were
during the pandemic i mean during the
pandemic
everything was streaming right look at
netflix the stock was through the roof
now it's tanking people were stuck at
home so of course they're watching
netflix or hulu or amazon any of these
things um but but i think theaters were
at that time i don't think anymore i
feel like that's gone i think netflix
the problem netflix always wanted this
really
short window they're like we'll give it
to you for seven days or ten
why don't just make it thirty okay
figure out a way forty-five um there's
gotta be something um i would love to
sit down with scott stuber who i saw
last night the head of netflix um
and ask him
what's your reasoning i would love to
hear someone because i guess they're
finally talking about it but i'd love to
know what was your reasoning for not
doing it he didn't want to put up with
the hassle
what's the answer uh but but i think
that no there's no doubt if it doesn't
do well not only doesn't anything you
still have money you made something from
the film
plus you're gonna get people that
subscribe to watch it even if it's bad
people still watch bad movies
sometimes they watch them
you know more than the good ones yeah i
have watched fire starter five times in
theaters first of all i have a list from
amc which is the best thing ever okay
sorry if this is advertising but the
amca list is literally 24.
for 12 movies a month 12. three movies a
week okay for 24 so once i got that i'm
like hey i've got three movies this week
let's go see fire starter again so
and it's because it's bad so i've sat
through fire starter five times because
it is bad it's 90 minutes and i have a
list but there's nothing wrong with
seeing through a bad movie sometimes
it's more entertaining so you can laugh
at it
do you think netflix will ever buy movie
theaters they should have i thought they
were gonna with arclight right i thought
that they were gonna go down there i
know they have the egyptian but i
thought that they were gonna go buy arc
light hollywood which would have made so
much sense it's sitting there it's still
empty i don't know what's going on with
arclight hollywood but it would be
perfect for netflix they're down the
street they have two offices right one
on sunset one on vine and they have two
campuses
right there we can walk over to arclight
i don't know how that didn't happen um
but it would be the perfect showcase for
their films put that in the cinema dome
center center center ramadan put it in
the cineramadome and then you have your
number one film in that giant screen and
and you don't even care about profits at
that point you own the theater so if you
if it's a giant you know that's a huge
room obviously and let's just say it's
not full who cares you're giving that
film
the stature that it needs
to again that theatrical component that
adds to the stature of your film so buy
arclight hollywood and then stick your
films there and and then have other
films maybe that's their issue too they
don't want to be you know i don't want
to have a universal film and a paramount
film and a disney film in with ours i
don't know what the point is i mean i
would not suggest they buy
the arc light and put all netflix films
that would not be the suggestion i would
just say buy it and then put in your
films where you want in the strategic
rooms you want and then let the other
studios have theirs because you can't
just have because the world doesn't run
only on one studio's films we've seen
that you really want that diversity of
of different studios and distributors
maybe that and expose them to liability
it could be that too i i i don't know
you know it's weird i don't know the
business of it i just it just doesn't
make sense i just think
at the end of the day the bottom line is
this is the theatrical adds to your film
the cache of your film and without it
with that missing theatrical component
it is it degrades and devalues your film
i 100 believe that